so what I want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with the second
derivative test and before I even get
into the nitty-gritty of it I really
just want to get an intuitive feel for
what the second derivative test is
telling us so let me just draw some axes
here so let's say that's my y-axis let's
say this is my x-axis and let's say I
have a function that has a a relative
maximum value at x equals C so let's say
we have a situation that looks something
like that and x equals C is right over
so that's the Point C F of C so I can
draw some straighter dotted line so that
is X being equal to C and we visually
see that we have a local a local maximum
point there and we already hit we can
use our calculus tools to think about
what's going on there well one thing
that we know we know that the slope of
the tangent line at least the way I've
drawn it right over here is equal to 0
so we could say F prime of C is equal to
0 and the other thing we can see is that
we are concave downward in the
neighborhood around x equals C so notice
our slope is constantly decreasing and
since our slope is notice it's it's
positive it's less positive even less
positive it goes to 0 then it becomes
negative more negative and even more
negative so we know that F prime prime
we know that F prime prime of C is less
than 0 and so you know I haven't done a
deep mathematical proof here but if I
have a critical point where F prime
where our critical point at x equals C
so f prime of C is equal to 0 and we
also see that the second derivative
there is less than 0 well intuitively
this makes sense that we are at a
maximum value and we could go the other
way if we are at a local a local minimum
point at x equals C or a relative
minimum point
so our first derivative should still be
equal to 0
because our slope of a tangent line
right over there is still zero so f
prime of C is equal to zero but in this
second situation we are concave upwards
the slope is constantly is constantly
increasing we have an upward-opening
bowl and so here we have a relative
minimum value or we could say our second
derivative is greater than zero
visually we see it's a relative minimum
value and we can tell just looking at
our derivatives at least the way I've
drawn it first derivative is equal to
zero and we are concave upwards second
derivative is greater than 0 and so this
intuition that we hopefully just built
up is what the second derivative test
tells us so it says hey look if we're
dealing with some function f let's say
it's a twice differentiable function so
that means that over some interval so
that means that you could take find its
its first and second derivatives are
defined and so let's say there's some
point x equals C where its first
derivative is equal to zero so the slope
of the tangent line is equal to 0 and
the derivative exists in a neighborhood
around C and most of the functions we
deal with if it's differentiable at C it
tends to be differentiable in the
neighborhood around C and then we also
assume that second derivative exists is
twice differentiable well then we might
be dealing with a maximum point we might
be dealing with a minimum point or we
might not know what we're dealing with
and it might it might be neither a
minimum or a maximum point but using the
second derivative test if we take the
second derivative and if we see that the
second derivative is indeed less than
zero then we have a relative maximum
point then so this is a situation that
is that we started with right up there
if our second derivative is greater than
0 then we are in this situation right
here we're concave upwards with a slope
is zero that's the bottom of the bowl we
have a relative minimum point
and if our second derivative 0 it's
inconclusive there we don't know what is
actually going on at that point we can't
make any strong statement so with that
on the way let's just do a quick example
just to see if if this has gelled let's
say that I have some twice
differentiable function H and let's say
that I tell you that H of 8 is equal to
5 I
tell you that H prime of 8 is equal to 0
and I tell you that the second
derivative at X equals 8 is equal to
negative 4
so given this can you tell me whether
whether the point 8 comma 5
so the point 8 comma 5 is that a
relative is that a relative minimum
relative minimum maximum point or not
enough info not enough info or
inconclusive and like always pause the
video and see if you can figure it out
well we're assuming it's twice
differentiable I think it's safe to
assume that it's and will for the sake
of this art problem we're going to
assume that the derivative exists in a
neighborhood around x equals 8 so this
example C is 8 so the 0.85 is definitely
on the curve the derivative is equal to
0 so we're dealing potentially with one
of these scenarios and our second
derivative is less than zero second
derivative is less than 0 so this
through us so the fact that the second
derivative so H prime prime of 8 is less
than zero tells us that we fall into
this situation right over here so just
with the information they've given us we
can say that at the point 8 comma 5 we
have a relative maximum value or that
this is a relative maximum point for
this if somehow that if they tell us the
second derivative was 0 then we would
say it's inconclusive and they told us
and that's all they told us and if they
told us the second derivative is greater
than 0 then we would be dealing with a
relative minimum value at x equals 8